because a it's not your land B you
mentioned Jerusalem you can tell me that
please don't take that when it comes to
the israeli-palestinian conflict
I think I'm mostly emotionally sad
I think it's not fair that you know a
country that is peaceful be in a
situation where we have to be threatened
me an arab girl living inside of the
israeli state it's pretty hard for me to
find exactly who i am what the
palestinians we still live under
occupation so we have no power i believe
that every person jew christian Muslim
should be full equal citizens under
Israeli sovereignty we need just to end
this conflict between us because we
don't need the other generations to live
the life that we live it
[Music]
if we continue to do what we did until
now it's probably going to stay and we
need to do something else
my name is Hannah Ziad I'm 24 years old
and I'm an Arabian youtuber my name is
Duryodhan I'm 25 years old and I'm a
Jewish Israeli Zionist my name is Vera
Abdo I'm from Nablus 25 years old
studied public relations and
communications my name is Khaled so her
I'm from a small town called give at the
edge right outside of Jerusalem and I'm
24 years old my name is Erica romaine
I'm 24 years old and from Jerusalem my
name is Ron barrio fat I'm 34 years old
and I work as a deputy director of a
think-tank that deals with law and
economics
[Music]
okay my father was murdered by two IDF
soldiers it hit us hard especially for
my family we're only girls and inside of
the Arabic nation that's really hard my
friend when I was 10 years old is where
the sniper should it hair on her head so
that was really hurt for us you know I I
grew up during the Second Intifada they
carry a list with me of all my friends
who were murdered in their attacks so I
have a list of 27 people they were
actually very close to me in Israel we
have a memorial today so I have always a
dilemma which grave to go to in 16th of
January 2007 Israeli soldier shot and
killed my sister earlier she was 10
years old for the first school and I was
13 were six kids in the house after that
we became two sisters and three brothers
all of the people that I know have lost
someone to the war in some way and I
think like grief is such a universal
emotion I'm like am I really I want a
hug oh I served in the IDF I still serve
in the Army Reserves combat I was very
combat in the Second Intifada and I feel
your grief and I understand it but I
have to say that I never got an order to
shoot someone the order was only to
shoot if someone is thirty rely for a
third to someone else's lives I also
served in the IDF and they really do
just teach us to defend ourselves if
we're not defending ourselves and we do
kill someone we go to jail that's not
true that's not true
I can tell you something the soldier
that killed my sister
he didn't spend one day in there neither
did my father both of them that murdered
him did not stay one day in jail
okay I think the Palestinian they will
not stop saying that we we want we want
a country so in the end if we got to the
point that we have our state and they
have a state so no problem this is gonna
be better for us to live all of us
together which is no state like
Palestine no state like Israeli only
together and having peace together like
there is no walls and there is no
checkpoints which is happened Brent
right now I'm with you one state under
Israel's sovereignty and everyone's full
equal citizen alright okay but under
Israeli sovereignty because right now I
why is that a problem why should it be
on one why should one religion control
religion it's a nationality
it's my nationality so if if we all
wanna state with the Palestinian the
Palestinian they control it you can live
under it no so because a it's not your
land be you mentioned you you can tell
me that please I don't why they're
saying a hundred percent Palestine used
to maintain okay one question if please
answer it you're a grand for a grand
grandfather you know where he is
yes waiting is to give me how many how
many graves you want me to sit seven
before seven before I know yes well
seven refers in Hungary in Hungary nine
before isn't Palestine don't tell me
it's not moving I'm saying it's not your
land it's all that and it's Wednesday
and will be like how do you determine
this is our land and it's not their land
based on what history international law
and interest so there D yes how about
empathy I I have empathy I'm just not
willing to live to give up on my
identity in what I believe is mine
when I say that I'm afraid what I
basically mean is I'm afraid of going
into Gaza because I know that if I will
go into Gaza I might get shot someone
might kill me
I think I hesitated a little bit because
I don't think I'm afraid of the people
on the other side I think I'm afraid of
the gap and sort of almost equally
afraid of like you know that side taking
all of the responsibility for what is
happening or this side taking all of the
responsibility for what is happening
which is obviously not working well
that's fair enough I don't believe that
all Palestinians are terrorists because
that doesn't make sense but I do believe
that who is in charge they're leading
the Palestinians to you know hating us
and in a way that you know it is really
unfair against against what you said
they're not that Islam because Islam
didn't didn't say kill killing people or
having a blood don't believe that the
radical Muslims that come and do these
things what do you have to say they're
not part of us we never accept them as
Muslims because they're teaching hate
and in a way I accepted what you just
said about there's a big problem with
our governments they don't know how to
talk to each other and in my idea I
really think the people or the ones I
should be talking to each other I agree
and I have to say also don't think
there's an issue with Muslims but I
disagree with you about the fact it's
about plans there are several peace
talks they were offered 97 percent of
the land 98 would have done it they they
disagree but after deciding with the
land they came and they built more
settlements what's wrong what's wrong
with Jews living in Judea that's not the
problem the problem is is that we
actually talked about this land being
for these people and in the end when we
see Israelis coming in and actually
building houses that's showing us we
don't you guys don't want peace
I serve in the IDF so first of all I
trust myself and my officers I do think
that a lot of the information I'm
getting is not accurate which is why
I've tried to compare it with different
sources and I also try to see it from
from people what days what they think
what they feel
I don't trust everything I see on the
news that's for sure
I do believe again there are two sides
to every single story but I do see
things that are happening for instance
you know things like the the rockets
that are striking or the stabs that are
happening those things I do trust
because I can see that they're happening
and they're just unfair like I see the
the narrative being written I was like I
watch TV I know how important and how
powerful language is and how it can
create reality and like I can I can see
it I like this is really dangerous like
on both sides it's really dangerous if
you see is media that I see they're
always against Israel for things that
are not necessarily our fault I find it
very funny because we look at it as and
start saying that they're really with
Israel which is funny but no I seriously
do find the information that we're
getting has more as an agenda to it from
both sides I don't believe in social
media like from the Israeli side I'm
gonna support Israel and from the
Palestinian side gonna support
Palestinians people gonna be very
confused and I'm gonna be very confused
about the reality so the same a day the
question was the sources so it doesn't
have to be just social media and the
reports like this like I also trust the
reports that the Israeli security forces
publish in their ideas not about the
reality and the situation but their
ideas how do they are see this situation
it's not really what happened
what political leaders on my side to
make compromises for peace
if we continue to do what we did until
now it's going to continue as it was now
and I don't see it getting better our
leaders should have our lives and and
the best for us in their minds and so
it's not compromising like peace is
never compromising the Palestinian
politician they were they in the end
they wanna piece for they selves and for
the people but they have no power
because the power it's not in the hand
it's the in the other side I would like
for us to compromise only if you will be
able to compromise it doesn't make sense
that every time that we have a war it's
always started by your side the other
day I just heard about you know over a
thousand eight hundred acres of crops
have been burnt by you know Hamas who
have been sending it over to Israel
instead of you know spending all that
money in order to ruin us why don't they
spend it on taking care of a Palestine
it's one second you're talking about
Hamas you're talking about the Gaza Gaza
it's so far from us we don't know what's
going over there we don't know if you
can ask me about the West Bank I'm gonna
I'm gonna answer and I think you as well
but here's the way I see it when you're
talking about compromise
Hamas is Charter says murder the Jews
wherever they are in the PID period or
going back to Hamas but the PA stating
Authority let me finish it was the
authority that are the moderates they're
saying it's a death sentence if you sell
your house to a Jew are there racist
people Israel of course our racist
people everywhere in the world yes but
we condemn people who are acting
violently and the other side glorifies
[Music]
if you're going to attack Israel then
Israel is going to defend themselves and
that means when it comes to certain
things maybe not you specifically but
again to the radical Muslims we have to
because if we don't then there's not
gonna be a state of Israel anymore I
don't think it's a matter of Israeli
Arabs or Jews Christians sometimes we
laugh you have to use violence I hope
it'll be close to zero as possible but
if I see someone about to murder someone
else and I think it's okay for me to use
violence to stop that
I think violence is not allowed for a
political goal I think that's a bad
place to use violence I prefer talking
and having a discourse okay I didn't
grow up with with a lot of violence with
the zero violence but what I went to say
the same as you said who comes to my
house to broke the door to take my
father of course I will defense for
myself so it's called violence but I
wanted events for myself first of all I
am against violence 100% it's a freaking
circle it's going to keep on happening
over and over again for me if you're
gonna react for the violence with
violence so here we go
we're having like the same problems the
same generation who's raised with hatred
and violence love blood which is not
acceptable
I think that israel needs to be our
homeland because if we won't have a
homeland no one else is going to accept
us anywhere else especially because
there's a lot of racism and
anti-semitism as well so if we're not
gonna be here where are we gonna go okay
for me as a Muslim the Holy Land it's
why it's so important it's first of all
because I was born here I have no place
that I don't replace every single person
around the word had the right to live in
the plate that they were born in and
that the right for Palestinians also for
if we're gonna talk about refugees also
they have the right to come back here to
their lands to their homes and have
their places the fact that we came back
to our homeland and that we do have a
country and a government here for me
like it does feel like a miracle but I
also think that the fact that we do have
the power now gives us more
responsibility and that we can't just
base it on the fact that it's our
homeland and not hear other voices
saying we feel the same about the same
place
all the time requests if it's more
dialogue more force more conversations
more social media I always ask myself
what is the best thing I tend to believe
that the best thing is human interaction
a lot of times I take a step back from
like the political argument about the
conflict and all of that just because I
feel like unworthy and that I don't know
enough so my way I've always known what
I what I am in this conflict I always
knew I wanted to fight for peace that's
all I knew and that's all I will ever
know I never was in the idea of this
conflict until my father passed away and
then I had to think for myself I always
was asking my father why I was born and
his answer not to kill to live to be in
life and when my sister she got killed I
went back to him to dinner he told me I
was born to live not to kill but my
sister she was born to die the
Palestinian they didn't kill six million
Israelis and the Israelis still didn't
kill six million Palestinian there is a
germanium Embassy in Tel Aviv and there
is a German Israelis empathy in Germany
so it's a big hole it's always gives me
hope when I'm looking at this and
thinking a little bit about this I gotta
say I think it's it's nice slogans they
just I don't think that's the case
Israel has a peace treaty with Egypt
because Egypt was willing to have peace
with Israel Israel has a history with
Jordan because the Jordanians were
willing to have history with with Israel
also from one to one it's it's different
how the way you think you'll agree which
is exactly why I don't believe in
in a piece between the two sides because
in my understanding of reality the whole
concept of Palestinian nationality
because you don't accept Palestinians
except human beings I'm saying that the
whole concept of thirsty nationality is
one goal and that is the annihilation of
Israel when Jordan took over Judea
Samaria when Egypt took over Gaza no one
asked for a policy that you're combining
everyone you're combining everyone into
one ideology which is not right why
you're saying because they're saying
that they're Palestinian
this is what they want which is not true
III take it back they'll see that the
government's the posting an authority
there I agree it's different okay
because I don't refer to the Arabs as
being some areas Palestinians Arabs of
Judea Samaria if we were gonna live long
long age or long years
we're gonna say you're gonna say each
other we get with Regan a little we
we're gonna have it you can have it
nobody's no I'm talking about peace
we're gonna have it here
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello I'm Johnny I'm adore there's on
top some passion fruit juice which gives
[Laughter]
so how was the experience guys for me it
was perfect was good and it was a good
meeting
it was tots eatery it was upside down
the beginning yeah because like you
don't do it in front of you you don't
know their ideas their ideology what
they think about you I think we did come
to some sort of an agreement that we
both do want peace I want security
freedom and prosperity you're talking
about legal peace I don't want a piece
of paper that says peace I want to live
in peace I don't want a piece of paper
says okay but we don't agree because I
don't believe in a Palestinian state and
you think you should have like a
two-state solution so we don't agree
they'd see me wanted a one-state of
solution Israel with everyone equal I'm
fine with it
exactly well I learned from you that you
have a lot of sympathy for outside as
well even though you're your sister
passed away which is terrible she didn't
pass away she was murdered but I can see
that you also have sympathy for the
other side and you actually are trying
to you know communicate with us even
though you went through everything that
you had to go through on your end
and I definitely learned that we can
learn to love your side as well or I
could learn to love your side as well I
think this is the main point for our
maybe conflict that we did not hear from
each other so I think it's important to
hear from each other not just keep your
thoughts and ideas inside your head and
don't try to open this box just try to
open it we want really similar things
yeah and it sort of you feel like you
know my friends from back home and so
the realization that we do have the same
sort of language not not in like the
language that we speak but in our body
language and the things that interest us
and
future that we hold for ourselves and
for our families like there are no sides
like I can't draw a line and say okay
I'm like these people or I'm with these
people hey guys this is Jason and this
is John and just want to say thank you
so much for watching a really special
episode of middle ground we love this
series because it's an opportunity now
more than ever to create great dialogue
and create radical empathy this was a
challenge but also a privilege to get to
go to Jerusalem to film this dialogue
around a subject that is you know very
tricky and very difficult but we loved
having the challenge totally we want to
say a huge shout out to youtube and
created for change which gave us the
resources and the support to do this and
we'd love to hear your thoughts let us
know what you thought about the episode
and the various perspectives in the
comments below and also let us know what
other suggestions for middle ground you
have we want to do more episodes bigger
and even better yeah and as always
please be sure to click Subscribe and
follow us on Instagram
thanks you guys later